eu escrevi dez anos na vida simples e o
meu ex marido então marido dizia que um
dia eu ia ser processada por fraude mas
em vida simples você aí outro dia uma
pessoa na rua falou comigo assim você já
conseguiu arrumar sua casa
do nada assim se as meninas já conseguiu
arrumar sua casa
tantas vezes eu escrevi da vida simples
falando da bagunça da minha casa que ela
achou que eu já tinha dado conta desse
assunto mas enfim já se falou sobre
resoluções de ano novo no novo época de
fazer listas tal que acha é que a gente
não está envolvido assim pela
perspectiva do ano novo
mas quando terminou em caraca não passou
a deter muito rápido então é quase mais
uma revisão do que a gente já falou que
ia fazer e não fez do que a perspectiva
da novidade propriamente você que
acontecem comigo e pelos comentários
gerais tipo não se conhecendo passou
rápido é eu acho que acontece com muita
gente boa no novo a gente faz algumas
resoluções assim mas é pontuais mas
vamos dizer o que eu preciso mandar
reformar o sofá da sala que está a
rasgar nojento com espuma aparecendo e
isso eu já fiz
chamei o terceiro e hoje ia ficar pronto
é outra coisa ainda não fiz eu preciso
consertar o telhado porque tá vazando
mas enfim quando eu tomar a iniciativa
como foi com sofá onde praticamente só
precisa do primeiro passo vai ser pega o
caderninho
o guia daqui perdizes acho o terceiro
liga ele vem e faz orçamentos e manda
fazer pronto quer dizer quando você tem
alguma coisa assim com uma realização
mais definida começo e fim
basta o primeiro passo e pronto vai o
resto acontece não sei fazer mais nada o
tapeceiro que que reformou mais difíceis
que a gente acaba repetindo todo ano
ao todo domingo são aquelas em que o
primeiro passo só adianta você precisa
dar um passo todo dia
senão as coisas não andam então são as
mudanças
de hábito essas são as mais difíceis de
realizar por mais que sejam as mais
acessíveis
pra gente quer dizer muitas vezes o
hábito não depende de procurar o
endereço de ligar para alguém de fazer
um orçamento de reservar o dinheiro e
fazer três cheques é muito menos do que
isso e ao mesmo tempo são com essas mais
corriqueiras que a gente às vezes têm
mais dificuldade
as férias de verão também são muito
propícias para esse tipo de coisa porque
a gente tem uma mudança quando as férias
de uma mudança significativa de hábitos
no verão principalmente quando consegue
viajar então também é fácil você
durante essa temporada se determinar se
agora vou ter uma alimentação mais
saudável porque a gente fica
naturalmente propenso a comer mais
coisas frescas e mais frutas e saladas
ficam mais apetecíveis
então é uma ocasião que que propicia
esse tipo de determinação e às vezes até
é um pouco mais extrema se uns anos
atrás fui pra caraíva no sul da bahia
muitos anos atrás e não tinha quase
eletricidade nenhuma lá algumas pessoas
que tinham gerador se era isso mesmo que
eu queria ir para um lugar daquele jeito
sem eletricidade super rústico tal a
gente chegou à noite em caraíva lua nova
não enchergava bulhufas assim em cada
passo era fim era um mistério ali areia
pedra rio
ficamos numa casinha e assim se começa a
ver toda a dimensão do não têm
eletricidade a não tem televisão legal
mas não tem um monte de coisa com as
quais a gente está acostumado e não de
água encanada também significa por
exemplo que aquele lugar que se chama
cozinha só tem uma bancada porque não
tem água encanada então algumas coisas
que são tão automáticas pra gente que
você já me lembra que você não vai
encontrá las
eu sabia que caraíva não tinha água
encanada mas eu pensava no encanamento
debaixo do chão que não tem
não me tornei em casa então do lado de
fora da casinha tinha um banheiro
banheiro
né e um tanque porque tinha uma pequena
caixa d'água água descia por dinheiro ou
desvia para aquela única torneira pra
você lavar roupa lavar a mão lavar
panela o que você precisa se fazer o
banheiro e se ele não ia até o teto
como dizer ele tinha uma paradinha do
tamanho do que seria um box e entre o
topo da parede eo telhado eram vão
completamente aberto telhado claro que é
só dele não tem forro o mourinho aliás é
muito prática muito providencial porque
é onde você coloca vela pra poder gente
toma banho então se até lembrou que não
tinha água quente mas por não enxergar
nada ea vela além de ter uma
luminosidade muito frágil muito sujeito
ao vento
ela não ilumina todos os cantinhos na
lente com aquele parte escurinha ali
atrás do seu calcanhar naquele lugar
úmido onde você vai tomar banho e o piso
também não era ladrilho era cimento e
nascimento com epóxi e cimento queimado
e cimento assim tipo de calçada
então você acaba de chegar de viagem
sala 18 horas contando todos os
translados 120 quilômetros de terra só
ajudava seis horas de ônibus que estrada
muito ruim então você chega exatamente
naquele lugar que você queria mas tudo é
tão estranho a gente tá tão
desacostumado então se chega exausto
chuveiro é frio não chegando porcaria
nenhuma tem visto do lado da área pelo
lado tá perdoado assim caras é que eu
fiz uma bobagem
será que era assim que eu ia descansar
mesmo que eu não devia ter um lugar um
pouco mais confortável cara nunca 20
dias aqui
será que eu vou conseguir curtir em que
aí é claro que sim
à medida que a gente vai se acostumando
com aquele outro jeito de fazer as
coisas vai assimilando aqui você vai
curtindo aqui jamanta mais feito um
idiota tateando o interruptor né a gente
faz isso em casa a gente aí acabou a luz
e esse vai e acender quer carregar o
celular na tomada para ligar e saber
quando é que volta luz
então aos poucos você vai saindo daquela
voltagem anterior e vai se acostumou
como o que antes parecia precário e
agora já parece uma delícia
um outro jeito de viver o seu cotidiano
e aí depois de caraíva como já aconteceu
muitas vezes comigo aí eu volto para são
paulo pensando vou mudar de vida agora
pra que tanta roupa olha que eu não sou
muito de roupa mas eu tenho umas 40
camisetas e ainda maior para você leva
45 e os a mesmo né
bom tudo bem não dá pra ter quatro ou
cinco camisetas em são paulo tal mas pra
que tanta roupa pra que tanta coisa eu
vou ficar um dia por semana sem acender
a luz não durou uma quarta feira porque
j resolveu que não sei porque é que
quarta feira é dia de futebol
então tá mas então pelo menos quando eu
entrar num ambiente é preciso acender a
luz só porque entrei no ambiente e daí
que tá meio escuro
o dá perfeitamente para enxergar o olho
da gente acostuma depois com escuros e
vai tateando bom
nenhuma dessas coisas porque a força do
hábito é muito grande quer dizer a gente
chega em caraíva com a força dos nossos
hábitos cotidianos
aí é legal que com o tempo aqueles
hábitos de lá se estabelecem e se impõe
então no final de 2016
você acha que se seria capaz de viver
daquele jeito vida inteira mas aí você
sai daquele contexto volta para o seu
contexto normal e aquele hábito anterior
também volta com uma força tremenda e
rapidinho tudo está normal então a gente
se acostuma a viver confinado de novo a
gente acostuma havia fechado o horizonte
né muito tapado
nesta conta normalmente elas e que não
puderam pôr do sol maravilhoso fazer a
equipe mas já foi porque foi pra trás do
prédio ela uma vez quando trabalhava na
mtv uma amiga minha tinha ido pro
deserto do saara passar férias
eu só espero q impressionante no deserto
o céu enorme
a gente já se acostumou que o céu é só
em cima e olhe lá né dependendo de onde
a gente está a gente acostuma com
barulho
é impressionante como a gente acostuma
com barulho assim quando de uma serra
elétrica aí você fala caraca que
barulhento hoje não já tava muito
barulhento antes mas preciso de alguma
coisa muito pior para a gente se sente
incomodado a gente se acostuma com
cheiro cheiro de óleo diesel
a gente nem percebe porque o cheiro é
uma coisa que a gente realmente acostuma
né
você entra no lugar e senti um cheiro
que quem já está lá dentro às vezes já
não já não sente mais isso me lembra uma
coisa que eu vou falava sempre e que eu
quando eu ouvi assim eu achei que era
uma uma lição mesmo que ela estava
deliberadamente dando não comentar
nenhum comentário mas não titulado a
tudo a gente se acostuma
inclusive quando você vê alguém vivendo
em condições muito piores do que as
nossas ffaa gente como é que alguém
consegue viver num lugar e se alguém
consegue morar num lugar que tem esse
cheiro
como é que alguém consegue viver num
lugar que tem tanto lixo aí vem a minha
avó a toda a gente se acostuma
e a gente também se acostumou em outros
graus nem outra escala - e também
costuma se acostumando se acostuma com
lixo se acostuma com pobreza basta vê
todo dia que a gente já fica meio nem
assimila e fica incorporado
pois muito bem se a tudo a gente se
acostuma e no sentido que a minha avó
usava esse sentido das coisas ruins
no fim a gente acaba se acostumando
aquilo que era insuportável no começo
serve perfeitamente também para o que é
bom tudo a gente acostuma inclusive o
que é bom
tanto é que às vezes é dito quase como
uma ameaça assim né alguém estava
fazendo uma massagem deliciosa assim ai
que bom é o outro fala assim mano vai
acostumar a gente acostumou fácil é um
puma já que a gente acostuma fácil
porque não tentar se acostumar com
alguma coisa boa que depende só da gente
porque não adianta eu me acostumar com o
mar de caraíva eu preciso me acostumar
com alguma coisa que eu possa fazer aqui
e não encara ainda não adianta achar que
eu vou ter 200 interruptores e eu não
vou acender a luz
eu preciso ser mais realista do que isso
foi aqui o que é que temos uma das
piores coisas que temos trânsito
trânsito é o desafio para os gentis
pacientes os generosos eu é frequento um
templo budista em cotia de budismo
tibetano e a gente tem os ensinamentos
domingo de manhã
a globosat série super inspiradora chega
uma hora se no final do ensinamento que
fica todo mundo em levado sabe
comovido aí ela falou assim quero ver na
raposo que a perder a meditação a
compaixão em permanência
basta ter um mala do farol atrás uma
lesma na sua frente e você o
apressadinho que a sua compaixão
equanimidade já foi prudenciais
pois muito bem então o trânsito é onde a
gente vive ele é o desafio
eu me acho super consciente no trânsito
o respeito pedestre ciclista mas olha só
como eu exerci minha consciência não
determinada situação eu vejo que alguém
quer cruzar a rua ou sair da garagem
aí na minha consciência eu pensava assim
vou acelerar vou passar rápido quer para
liberar logo essa pessoa porque eu
lembro eu sei como é você está querendo
sair da garagem ver um cara bem devagar
foi meu passo louco aproveitou então eu
era a que acelera super tenta superar
consciente mas aí um belo dia me deu um
estalo
assim o primeiro que eu vou acelerar mas
o cara não sabe
uma das coisas chatas no trânsito e na
vida é tensão de não saber o que esperar
então ele está lá vovô
aí eu sei que vou acelerar mas ele não
sabe
e em outra coisa posso acelerar e vi um
monte de gente atrás de mim não adianta
nada
aceleramos todos ele vai continuar sem
espaço para sair então deu um estalo do
óbvio não é mais assim em vez de
acelerar a passar logo desacelera e
deixa pessoas aí a pessoa passar no
cruzamento passar na rotatória fez toda
a diferença do mundo do que o stress
ruim da incerteza de ser até agora da
cena que agora dar quando você diminui e
sinaliza e faz um gesto que a pessoa
pode se está fazendo como no esporte
trazendo um corta luz que você tá
contendo um pouco o fluxo se houver um
fluxo e dizendo não beleza pode eu
comecei a fazer isso e não pense que foi
fácil para mim porque eu sou atraiu da
deus quando sai de carro e raro mas eu
me atraso é agora não mudou em nada e
não perdi nem cinco minutos de um
compromisso porque em vez de eu acelerar
em vez de falar desculpa mas eu também
comprei essa né porque eu retardei um
pouquinho e de passagem segundos de
diferença segundo se eu fiz isso dez
vezes ao longo do caminho é juntando
tudo dá um minuto do tempo que eu tirei
um pouco o pé do acelerador e deu sinal
para a pessoa passar e funciona
incrivelmente funciona pra mim porque
muda para disposição do acelerador net
po logo muda você tem um outro tipo de
atenção que têm outro tipo de
predisposição em relação ao que está
acontecendo ali na sua frente certamente
melhor a pessoa naqueles 51 dinho's foi
um pouquinho - detenção um pouquinho
menos de de raiva de ansiedade que ela
teve e se lá provar possivelmente isso
vai ter um resultado muito bom
nos contatos que ela fizer depois ao
longo do dia porque a mesma coisa tanto
quina e rita gente tanto para o dia
inteiro
mas uma coisa tão simples uma amolecida
na gente também dura algum tempo
funciona
há nada a gente já costumam acaba
virando um hábito uma coisa automatizado
assim se presta a tensão diminui e deixa
a pessoa passar aí por alguma razão seis
graus de separação conexões cármicas
interdependência eu sei que as pessoas
dão mais passagem por mim agora
não é possível que elas estejam
retribuindo claro que não mas eu estou
prestando mais atenção nisso ou de fato
como todas as outras coisas boas e com
isso também é contagioso do
comportamento de um jeito ou de outro
virá lisa como as bobagens na internet
então eu tenho essa é a sensação de que
hoje em dia tem mais gente dando
passagem pra mim do que antes quem sabe
talvez tenha sido um contágio também não
talvez seja eu estou prestando mais
atenção nisso agora ou talvez seja
porque eu criei o hábito de diminuir a
velocidade quando tem alguém ali na
frente e isso até profecia não sei da
pessoa também da passagem pra mim não
sei eu sei que funciona e agora eu tô
super acostumada e não é por causa disso
que eu me atraso
quando eu me atraso então no trânsito às
vezes é superbom e recomendável mas às
vezes a gente dá um sorriso não adianta
porque a pessoa enxerga até porque ela
está atrás do bendito de um vidro
filmado e ninguém enxerga mais através
dos automóveis então sorriso é bom mas
pode não surtiu tanto efeito assim agora
um sorriso mecanizado e no bom sentido
que é você da pescadinha de farol e
dizer para a pessoa pode passar também
faz toda a diferença e eu garanto que a
gente acostuma
obrigado